from media laughingstock to media craze
from thousands of viewers to millions
these sports in the last decade or so
has eclipsed all expectations never
before in the history of dota have we
had a prize pull of this magnitude
twenty million seven thousand plus extra
change now the industry is set to
further mature with the announcement of
blizzards overwatch League and riots na
LCS shifting to a franchise model we're
going to be sharing revenue with teams
and pros we're going to be establishing
a players association to support and
protect rose but while eSports has come
a long way since its humble beginnings
it hasn't been without its set of
controversies they did shape and it's
one apologized to MLG
what is he doing because when they need
to die and we found this new site called
csgo whatta from the NFL's deflategate
and head trauma controversies to the
MLB's doping scandals and match-fixing
that dates back to 1919 one thing is
pretty clear when it comes to
professional sports sometimes the spirit
of competition gets lost in the money
and fame and eSports is no exception
back in 2009 eSports was at best a
buzzword in the West but on the other
side of the world the industry was
already an established hub of
opportunity you need to see these with
the rise of Starcraft's popularity in
Korea a significant number of illegal
gambling websites sprung up as a way for
people to capitalize on the number of
yearly competitions that took place
within the country by 2010 several
brokers representing these sites use
their connection with the pro league
circuit to entice players to throw
matches the money involved made it an
easy sell and more than ten players
including some of the game's most
prominent members like CJ entus savior
and STX souls kawasan participated in
the scandal the capital film was talking
to other the water gossip of your
metabolic age they are no more bundle of
mataram akhator : 21 ago the scandal
turned the eSports world upside down
even the mainstream media who had little
to no interest in eSports in 2010 wrote
about the scandal comparing it to the
1919 Black Sox scandal in which eight
members of the Chicago White Sox
baseball team were found to have
deliberately lost games by 2011 a new
title League of Legends was gaining
popularity especially in the West
reaching a hundred and eighty eight
thousand viewers on our stream
ridiculous that we were expecting
something like that for the grand finals
maybe but much like its RTS predecessor
the games
meant that its integrity would be put to
the test then in 2012 League of Legends
experienced its first major scandal
seniors here and Team Dignitas and team
Kurtz na privately agreed to play at the
first match as an all random all mid
ahead of the MLG summer championships
grand finals and their collusion cost
them forty thousand dollars in winnings
the interesting thing about this is that
Dignitas has their seating read live on
this game if they win this series they'd
move into second place and face a
different team in the first round they
dodged out of team dynamic what is going
in the same year during the world
championships a critical design flaw
with the stage allowed players who
looked up at the venue's main screen to
catch glimpses of the enemy's mini-map
as Koreans are behind players always
Cantini though the accusations initially
began online why it's internal
investigation found that five instances
of the players looking up at the
jumbotron took place the most severe of
which occurred during a match between
Korea's azubu frost and the North
America's team solomid wound the ad
carry for azubu frost was caught looking
at the venue screen and the team is
subsequently modified their gameplay
based on the information gathered
effectively nullifying tsm's level one
strategy the first aim was kind of
disappointing to me mainly because they
did she though some people questioned
exactly how advantageous the screen
washing was the community was furious
and eSports integrity was once again
under the microscope in 2013 eSports as
a whole took a giant leap forward League
of Legends hosted the most viewed
eSports event of the year with 32
million
viewers and exponential growth from 2012
8.2 million and dota 2 the international
tournament handed out over 2.8 million
dollars in prize money but as the scene
attracted more views and higher payouts
it also attracted more people some of
which did not have the industry's best
interests at heart in 2013 Alexia's solo
a Barisan famously threw a dota 2 match
for three hundred and twenty two dollars
and a rogue employee at ESEA uploaded
malware into the company's software
allowing him to farm bitcoins
unbeknownst to the software's users the
malware initially began as an experiment
run by ESEA on two of their own admins
computers for the purposes of testing
Bitcoin integration for their clients
but the company eventually decided to
scrap the project though the project was
scrapped one of the employees involved
in the beta tests it decided to use the
code to mine bitcoins for personal gain
that's unreal I can't believe it I think
most people couldn't due to the
excessive strain of that mining put on
users computers many esea users were
left with fried video cards and
astronomical electricity bills
in the end a class-action lawsuit saw
ESEA hit with a 1 million dollar fine
for a combined total gain of just over
3700 dollars I've noticed that they kind
of messed themselves up with the money
situation
in 2014 the entire international eSports
Federation was exposed for having a
male's only rule that excluded females
from participating in their hearthstone
tournament for the upcoming IeSF World
Championships the controversy first took
off when a redditor posted a picture of
the ruling outlined in the Finnish IeSF
qualifier leading up to the main
tournament questioning the organizers
decision to separate the two genders
when the IeSF stepped in to defend
themselves they said that their decision
to separate the two genders was part of
their efforts to try and legitimize
eSports as an actual sport we have
yeah if the world was furious no one
could understand how such an outdated
policy could still exist let alone be
upheld for such ridiculous reasons
finally just a day after the IeSF
statement went viral the company decided
to open up its tournaments to all
participants a huge victory guys a huge
victory over scandals of 2013 and 2014
were big no amount of heartbreak and
disappointment could prepare the eSports
community from what would later be known
as one of eSports most successful yet
scandal-ridden years in January of 2015
CS Coast fans were reeling from what
could only be described as the biggest
match-fixing scandal of the games short
competitive lifespan netcode guides
beating iBUYPOWER on season I by powers
csgo team consisted of North America's
best in-game leader dazed a brilliant
support player AZ k and n a super talent
steal one of the best offers in the
world skadoodle an eighteen-year-old
csgo genius swag and they knowingly
threw their match against netcode guides
a team that they would have typically
trounced back in August 2014 there was
already some speculation that the match
was thrown as soon as it ended but it
was quickly brushed aside as nothing
more than a rumor this is just really
surprising the story then later
resurfaced in 2015 when eSports
journalist Richard Lewis brought to
light incriminating text messages that
Derek D born born ascent to his
ex-girlfriend valve responded in January
2015 and they banned in
in Italy four of the five members of the
team as well as several others in a
highly publicized blog post entitled
integrity and Fairplay it happens from
baseball to boxing professional athletes
have taken dives for bribes from
professional gamblers it destroys the
integrity of the game then in February
of 2015
League of Legends was hit with the
scandal of astronomical proportions due
to several missed payments from his
previous organization supa hot crew and
facing concerns about the potential for
missed payments from his new team meteor
makers
Marcin quarry Walski decided it best to
leave em I am in February we have
yesterday found out that quarry will not
be playing anymore blizzard will be
playing in place of quarry it was future
with the team is still uncertain when
informed of the news M I am manager
Sebastien Rotterdam was livid he
threatened the youngster with promises
of future legal action and went as far
as to say that he would see it that his
mother lose her house the threats
coupled with subsequent action by the
team to prevent Corey from joining
another organization saw the midlaner
returned to the team's starting lineup
after just two weeks of absence and as
you guys see on the graphic and you guys
have heard already Cory is back in that
lineup from meet your makers the team
was fined 5000 euros and Rotterdam was
hit with an indefinite ban in 2016
eSports as a whole took yet another step
forward as interest in the industry
turned into even more money as multiple
investors entered the space in various
forums but while the rest of the
industry was making massive strides
forward Starcraft took two steps back oh
my gosh you feel the pain that they feel
still reeling from 2015's match-fixing
scandal one
games greatest players Lee life
sang-hoon was arrested and indicted in
2016 for receiving money to
intentionally throw maps if the scene
had any hope for redemption life's
arrests marked the death of that she's
like one of those moments where it's the
universe just works against you but
Starcraft wasn't the only game that saw
gambling create controversy around the
scene a large portion of the money that
came in with the influx of new investors
in 2016
particularly in csgo was coming from
websites that allowed counter-strike
players to wager their in-game items
yesterday $16,000 and if you don't
believe me let me just show you part of
my inventory they sponsored the game's
most popular players the biggest
tournaments and everything else and we
found this new site called csgo whatta
so largely unregulated these websites
appear to be relatively harmless on the
surface that was until a youtuber called
honor the call exposed the dishonest and
underhanded business practices behind
one of the biggest gambling websites at
the time csgo lotto president Trevor
Martin and vice president Thomas Castle
so these two on the websites Sia's
Gallardo comm and the allegedly do fake
gambling and pretend to win thousands of
dollars and also sometimes pretend to
lose it too without disclosing that they
were owners of the website fellow
youtubers Trevor T Martin Martin and
Thomas Pro syndicate Cassell promoted
csgo lotto to their combined audience of
10 million subscribers when the shady
dealings came to light the valve
responded with a cease and desist letter
that forced the shutdown of a majority
of the gambling websites in July
now in 2017 with the announcement of na
LCS franchising and the continued
anticipation of the soon to come
overwatch League that includes major
sports investors like Robert Kraft of
the New England Patriots and Jeff Wilton
of the New York Mets eSports takes yet
another step towards maturity and
professionalism so the question is how
will this affect your favorite eSport
only time will tell but what we do know
is that despite the influx of outside
money despite the corruption and despite
the scandals it's always been the
communities that have kept eSports
thriving and in the end it'll be the
communities that will continue to ensure
that eSports grows beyond our wildest
dreams
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button